KAZ SATO: So thank
you for taking
your time for my session--
BigQuery and cloud
machine learning.
I'm Kaz Sato.
I have been working in
Google for a six years.
And for the last
two years, I have
been working as a
developer advocate, which
is like an evangelist
for developers.
So I usually go to the meetups
and events for developers
and talking about the
products and technologies.
And now I'm focusing on the
data and analytics, the products
such as a Google
BigQuery, machine learning
APIs, TensorFlow, and
machine learning engine.
Yeah, I sometimes still use
[INAUDIBLE] cloud email,
but we have just changed
the name to the [INAUDIBLE],
so I make some mistakes.
So today, I would to
discuss about these things--
how to combine the large
scale data warehouse
BigQuery with machine learning
provided by the cloud machine
learning engine, or MLNG.
So at first, I direct you
[INAUDIBLE] for this BigQuery.
How many people
have used BigQuery?
Oh, most of them--
it's like 80%.
But I see about 20% people
has not used BigQuery.
So I direct [INAUDIBLE]
introduce the technology
at first.
It's a fully managed
petabyte-scale enterprise
data warehouse.
to solve this kind of
problem, big data problem.
If you have terabytes
of data and you
have to scan all the data in
the disc drive in seconds,
how do you do that?
Do you want to [? BGO ?]
on Hadoop cluster?
on SPARC cluster,
taking the tens
of minutes or tens
of maybe hours to going through
all the scanning [INAUDIBLE]?
In Google, we don't
have time to wait hours.
Instead, we have to
solve all the problems
like a troubleshooting,
asking queries in seconds.
We have to solve all the
big-data-related problems
in seconds.
So to do that, we did some
experiment inside Google.
If you want to scan all all
the one terabyte of data
in one second, how
many disc drives
you would need running in
parallel to do this scanning?
And the result is that you
would need 5,000 to 10,000 disk
drives running in parallel
to scan all the data
and everything is
done in one second.
And we did that by using the
hundreds of the thousands
of machines in Google Cloud.
The Google Cloud is the
data center as a computer.
That means it's
not just a building
to host the bunch
of the servers.
Instead, it is designed to
work as a massively powerful
computer, single computer.
So that means we have been
developing all the hardwares
and middleware stacks
to deploy your own--
the job or processes,
applications,
on the hundreds of the
servers incidentally
by using a single
line of comments.
And the most important part
of the Google Cloud technology
is the network.
This is on switch
called Jupiter.
This is not a commercial
commodity switch
we have bought from
other manufacturers.
We have been spending
so much investment
on building our own network
switch hardware from scratch.
Why we are doing that?
Because we are trying to
consolidate all the server
resources like CPUs,
memories, and disc
server storages consolidated
with the microsecond latency
network so that we can
apply this petabit networks
and infrastructures to
solve many kinds of problems
such as big data solutions or
deep learning technologies.
So one of the application
of this petabit network
is a query.
That is a massively
parallel processing query.
So that means every single
query you run on BigQuery
will be processed by 1,000
to 2,000 CPU cores, hundreds
of disc drives in parallel.
So that's the reason
why you're seeing
the outstanding performance
when you are using BigQuery.
So let's take a look at a
very simple demonstration
of BigQuery by using
the Cloud Data Lab.
This is the tool
called Cloud Data
Lab, which is a Google
Cloud version of the Jupiter
Notebooks.
These days, many data
scientists and data analysts
are using the Jupiter
Notebooks, which
is a web-browser-based
analytics platform.
And we have combined the
Google Cloud Platform
with Jupiter Notebooks.
So its just like the
Jupiter Notebooks
You can learn any arbitrary
Python code inside browser
and also you can access
to Google Cloud services
such as the BigQuery Google
Cloud Storage, TensorFlow,
cloud machine learning,
or [INAUDIBLE] engine
inside the data
lab, Python code.
So you can learn the SQL for
BigQuery inside the data lab
just like you are
seeing right now.
And this is a sample
query I am running
to scan all the data
on a [INAUDIBLE] table
which has the 10 billion rows
of the Wikipedia update logs.
So let me run that.
So what is doing now--
so it is a simple query
to scanning all
the 10 billion rows
to find out all the
rows with the word
Google inside title by using
the regular expression match.
And usually, if you
write this kind of query,
that requires [INAUDIBLE]
scanning or table scan
of your table.
That means you have to read
all the data stored in the disk
drives read to the
CPU and using CPU
do the pattern matching on it.
Usually, your
database administrator
would be so mad at
you because, you know.
Most important part
of the database design
is to build the index to get
the reasonable performance.
But by using things like
regular expression matching
or text the pattern
matchings, there's
no way to build the index.
So that means you have
to download all the disc
data from the disc drives,
process everything on the CPU.
But still, you can
get the result.
You just saw you are able to
get the result in five seconds,
I think.
I'm not getting
a correct result.
Let me try it again.
Right, [INAUDIBLE].
Let me try it with still other.
So by clicking on the user
interface of the Data Lab,
you can easily execute
the query again and again.
And you'll get the result.
This is not a cache
result. It actually scanned
all data stored in disc drives.
The hundreds of disc
drives in parallel
scanned 400 gigabyte
in real time
and got a result
within 5 seconds.
So, this is the
performance you could
get at very inexpensive
cost, reasonable economy
of the cloud.
Why we can do that?
Because we're using the 1,000
or 2,000 CPU cores and hundreds
of disc drives in parallel
just for a single query.
That is affordable.
This is the power
of the BigQuery.
It's fully managed and
requires no special database
administrator.
And it can process terabyte
of data in tens of seconds--
so fast.
Actually, I can say that, yeah,
I joined Google six years ago
and I essentially noticed
that these technologies,
this technology is
called Dremel in Google,
and we have been using
Dremel since 2006.
And this is [INAUDIBLE] with
the core technologies we
have been using inside Google.
And that is one
reason why Google
has been so successful-- because
every team, like Android teams,
YouTube teams, Chrome
teams, Gmail teams,
can access terabytes of
data in tens of seconds
by using this tool.
So that's the largest difference
I've seen when I joined Google
six years ago.
And it also provides
the economy of cloud.
So you don't have to buy
the expensive data warehouse
appliance which goes, like,
$1 million, $2 million.
But I sometimes
get the feedbacks
from the BigQuery customers.
I always talk about the
performance of BigQuery,
but they say the performance
is not the highest priority.
For the BigQuery users,
the most important part
is the ease of access.
Why is that?
Because BigQuery is
scalable, because it
shares the 1,000 or
tens of thousands
with CPU cores and disc
storage on Google Cloud.
That means it's so
scalable so even
a single user can learn
a very slow performance
SQL or the SQL that requires
so much server resource.
This doesn't affect to the
overall service or other users
beyond that be affected by
the slow users or slow SQL.
So that means you
can allow any users
in your enterprise
accessing to the BigQuery
directory with
their homebrew SQL
or quick and dirty SQL that
is stored on your notepad
or spreadsheet.
Usually if you do these
things with your--
at the existing data warehouse
systems or any database
systems, the database admin
would be upset about that.
So they don't allow it.
But now, BigQuery user
is allowing the people--
the business
people, salespeople,
market researchers,
and support personnel--
to directly execute the SQL
from their spreadsheet or web
UI to BigQuery to
get real-time data.
And still nobody would be
affected for performance.
So we call it the
democratization of data.
So now BigQuery
can allow everybody
can access to the enterprise
data in real time.
So that's the basic
of the BigQuery.
But still, it's just an
ordinary SQL data warehouse.
So you can write the standard
SQL like the select statement
with where clause and
group by order by.
Those are the same old SQL.
But how you can make it smart?
How we can implement the smarter
analytics by using BigQuery?
Here, I call it a concept
called signatures.
By signatures, I mean
the feature vectors
taken from the content so that
you can make the SQL, BigQuery
SQL, a little bit smarter.
And I can show the demonstration
of this smarter query
by using a demonstration
called QueryIt Smart.
This is a demonstration that we
have built for the next Google
Cloud Next today.
And you can see the
same demonstrations
on the sandbox area,
the playground area.
So anyone who is interested,
you can go to the demo area
and try it by yourself.
If you start the demonstration--
we have the three different
demonstrations inside this demo
and we are choosing
the document search.
And this is where you can
select the key document.
This is all about the
document similarity search.
We have stored over 10
millions of the Stack Overflow
questions stored on BigQuery
as a public data set.
And you can do the
similarity search on document
based on its content.
So let me check.
This one has a key document.
So now the query is
executing a query
on the 10 million documents
from the Stack Overflow
to find the similar documents.
And this is not about keyword
matching or pattern matching.
This is comparing all
the documents each other
to find the similarity
between the documents.
And I got the query finished.
So this is the key
document at left.
And in the middle,
you can have the rest
of the similar documents.
So by clicking each
one of them, you
can see the BigQuery was able
to find the similar documents.
Based on the
[INAUDIBLE], you can
get that-- that
represents the similarity
between the documents.
So how do you implement
this kind of the--
a little bit smarter
query with BigQuery?
How do you find similar
posts on Stack Overflow?
So to implement this, we have
implemented these things.
At first, you can split
all these statement,
split into the words.
And then you can
extract the signatures.
By signatures, I mean the
feature vectors for each post.
That represents the
content inside each post.
And you can define the
user-defined function.
User-defined function
is a feature in BigQuery
where you can write
any JavaScript
code to define a
function that could
be used during an SQL query.
So by using
user-defined function,
you can calculate the similarity
between the signatures of two
different documents, and
using user-defined function
in your arbitrary SQL to
find similar documents.
And there is a big difference
between the feature
vector-based search and
the keyword match search.
Traditionally, in any
data warehouse systems,
people have been using
the keyword match vector
specifying the tags for
the content like a movie
or music, actor, and checks if
each document or content has
certain tags or not.
But instead, what I
[? directly ?] propose
is to use a feature vector
for comparing or searching
for content.
By feature vectors,
you mean that there's
a vector and dimensional
vector that represents
the content of the documents.
So how do you extract
the feature vectors?
So by taking a look
at this screen,
you can see that the
feature vectors actually
house pairs of the keywords
and scores of keywords.
For example, this
particular document
uses the word add and
grass and element.
This document uses words
such as differences
between or hash map.
So those are all
important words.
There's some algorithms
used for this extracting
for featured
vectors that can get
rid of all the trivial
words such the in or to
or a or that or there.
So by using the
algorithms called TF-IDF,
you can extract the
most important word
using the content and put
the scores on each word.
So that is the feature
vector or signature
we can use to do the
similarities between contents.
So if you put the
these feature vectors
in an n-dimensional space,
you would look like this.
So if you try to find
the similar documents
in n-dimensional
space, you have to take
the cosine similarities.
That means if you
have two vectors,
you are looking at the angles
between the two vectors.
So if you had another vector
which has a very narrow angle,
that means you are finding the
similar documents or content.
And then you can define
a user-defined function
to get the similarity,
calculation
the similarity between the
two different documents.
And it's just a basic math.
It's just a
multiplication, additions
you learn in high school.
So it's not so hard.
It's not machine learning yet.
Let me actually do what I have
explained inside the data lab.
So again, in data lab, I have
written all the SQL and scripts
required to do this.
So let's first
take a look at what
will be the Stack
Overflow post you
can access from the BigQuery.
So on BigQuery, we have
a bunch of public data
sets such as the New York City
taxi logs or the accidents.
And one of them is your
Stack Overflow post.
As you can see, you can
access to any posts,
like titles, the
body of the question,
or access it from
any BigQuery user.
And what you have to do at
first do the segmentation.
And here I have defined
a very simple function
called segmentation that
has the regular expression
to remove all the HTML tags
and extract the English words
from the content.
So by executing
this query, you'll
be getting the array of rows.
So you see the result.
By using the simple UDF,
you can extract words,
split the sentence
into two words like how to
check in one string contents.
So this is different
[INAUDIBLE].
Then what you do is to
calculate the feature
vectors by using a key ID.
As I mentioned, by
using the TF-IDF,
you can get rid of
all the trivial words
and leave all the important
words for each document.
Let me execute it.
It has about 20 lines
of the JavaScript code.
So it's so easy, not so hard.
It's much easier than defining
your own neural network.
So I got the result.
As you can see,
each TF-IDF feature vector
contains very important words
and its scores.
That represents the
content of the document.
So now we can use
these feature vectors
for [INAUDIBLE] research.
Again, we are defining another
UGF called calculate similarity
between the two documents.
This is much easier to define.
So all you have to do is
to write like a 10 lines
JavaScript code to get the
cosine similarity here and use
the calculation--
use the functions just like
this and use that similarity
to sort out based on the scores.
So let me execute the query now.
It's running it.
You'll be getting your result
in maybe 15 or 16 seconds.
Still running.
Oh, you got it.
So these are all
the similar posts
against the target document.
So as you can see,
already the document
is talking something
about [INAUDIBLE]
and how to add or delete column.
So you can see that this is not
just a simple keyword search
pattern matching.
This compares the content of
each document to each other
and gets the similarity
between them.
And now I have explained
how you can use the BigQuery
user defined function to do the
vector operations so that it
can handle things like
the feature vectors
as signatures of each content.
And you can actually
apply these technologies
to any kind of content
like document--
not only the documents.
You can apply to the
unstructured data like images
or audio or any business
data like your product
or users, anything.
And now we are trying to
combine the machine learning
engine, the power
of machine learning,
to extract the feature vector
or signature from your content.
So if you have a bunch of the
unstructured data like images
or content or
natural language, how
to extract the things like
human sense or instinct?
For example, if you have an
e-commerce site where you are
setting the manufacturing items
but the taste for the fashion
items by the buyers will
be defined by the senses
or instincts, you cannot write
any Python code or Java code
to define a conscious
[INAUDIBLE] if statements
to define.
If you have this
kind of the data,
that this shirt would be liked
by this woman or this man,
yeah, it is really hard.
It must be hard.
So that's the limitation
of the existing ID system.
Instead, we can use the machine
learning or neural networks
to extract the features
from the data set
so that the neural networks
can extract the features to let
the computer learn
what is the conditions
or what is the
instinct or senses they
are using for
selecting the fashion
items in an e-commerce site.
Let me actually show
the live demonstration
with the neural network.
This is a demonstration
called Playground,
where you can actually
define your neural networks
inside the browser and learn the
training against the training
data set.
And here, I have a training
data set called Double Spiral
where you have two spirals.
One is the orange spiral and
another is the blue spiral.
And we have the x1 and x2-- two
inputs, two data as an input.
And if you're human--
for human, it's really easy
to understand the [INAUDIBLE].
If you have new data here, it
should be in the orange spiral.
If you have new data
here, it should be
in the blue group, blue spiral.
For humans, it's so easy,
telling by your instinct.
But how do you let the computer
understand the underlying
patterns in the data set?
How do you write the programs
to classify this problem?
Do you want to write
many if statements
with many conditions whether
each dot is in this area
or if each dot is in this area?
This doesn't work.
Maybe you can do that, but
I don't want to do that.
So instead, I would
want to use the machine
learning or neural networks
to solve this problem.
So let me start
training this model.
So now we have
started the training
of the neural networks.
Every neural
network in the world
doesn't make any sense
on the data at first
before starting training.
But if you keep training
the neural network
model with your training
data, then gradually, computer
tries to extract
certain patterns hidden
inside your data set
just like you see.
So now the neural network
model is smart enough
to understand there's
a double spiral
pattern inside the data set.
So that's how the
machine learning
can get smart and
sometimes get smarter
than humans because it
can extract the hidden
features from a data set.
And if you take a look at
what each neurons are doing
inside neural networks,
actually each neurons,
artificial neurons
in the network,
is doing a very similar thing.
The real neurons in human brains
do also very simple things.
We have about 100 billion
neurons in a single brain
and each neuron is
just getting excited
or not by receiving
the electricity
from the other neurons' signals.
So if you are watching
a very bright light
or listening to the
very loud noises,
our neurons inside the brain
will get excited or not.
And we have so many
connections between neurons.
That represents the knowledge
and intelligence of humans.
And with the artificial
neural networks,
we are trying to
mimic the behavior.
With the current
technology, it is
impossible to simulate the whole
behavior inside a human brain.
It is not possible yet.
But still, we can
mimic that behavior
so that the whole
idea of neural network
is to mimic how the
people are using
the signals from the
outside and using
the networks between
the neurons to do
the intelligent
information processing.
So just like the
neurons in humans,
each neuron in the
artificial neural networks
do very simple things.
For example, if you take a
look at this particular neuron,
it only classifies
the data points
is in the blue
area or white area
by drawing a straight line
right here just like it.
It's very simple.
This neuron draws a
straight line again
and checks whether
your data point is
in the blue area or white area.
Get excited or not excited.
So that's so simple.
But if you have a bunch of
neurons and multiple layers,
the hierarchy of neurons,
then something interesting
is happening here.
So the neurons in the
second hidden [INAUDIBLE]
can take all the output
from the first layer
and make a little
bit smarter decisions
by combining all the results
from the first neurons, first
[INAUDIBLE].
So you can see the patterns
used in the second layer
is a little bit smarter
than the first layer.
And neurons in the third
layer get much smarter.
So by combining all that
outputs from the eight
neurons in the
second layer, it can
capture the very complex
pattern inside the data set
like you see.
And we have the final
neurons on the output layer.
This is smart enough to
understand the double spiral
pattern.
So this is how the AlphaGo,
the Go-playing AI tool,
was able to beat the world
class champion for Go.
This is how the people are
excited with the AI right
now, because the neural
networks can sometimes
exceed the performance
of the humans
by taking a look at the
patterns-- extracting patterns
from the data set.
So this is all about AI and we
provide a bunch of the services
from Google Cloud that let you
take advantage of the source
power of the machine learning.
We provide two different
kinds of products.
One is the pre-trained
ML, another
provides the custom ML model.
So if you have your
own data already,
like images or the audio
or natural language text,
then you can put everything on
the pre-trained ML model API
so that you can get
the result faster.
So if you send your image
of a cat to the vision API,
it will be receiving the
[INAUDIBLE] such as cat
instantly.
Or if you want to solve your own
problem with your own training
data, then we recommend you to
build your own neural network
artificial with
TensorFlow and train it
by using the ML engine.
That provides the fully managed
distributed training model
for you.
So, Cloud ML Engine.
ML Engine is a fully
managed TensorFlow platform
for Google Cloud.
It provides the distributed
training and prediction model,
and it scales to tens
of CPUs and GPUs.
And the most challenging part of
using deep learning technology
right now is the computing
power you have to consume.
So even if you have the
very powerful GPU server,
single server, it takes a few
days or sometimes a few weeks
to finish all the trainings
to train your own model.
So that's the hardest part.
That is the reason
why not everybody has
started using deep learning.
It's too hard to build your
own GPU cluster by yourself.
Instead, now we have a bunch
of GPUs on Google Cloud.
So you can just rent 10
or maybe 100s of GPUs
from Google Cloud
just for one hour.
It takes so less cost.
It's not expensive.
So by using the Google Cloud
Machine Learning Engine,
you don't have to
spend much money
to get started with the
deep learning technology.
So we have learned what
is machine learning engine
and what the neural networks do.
And let's think about how we
can combine these technologies
with BigQuery.
You want use cases
to use BigQuery
for pre-processing
the training data.
So the TensorFlow or the Machine
Learning Engine or ML Engine
itself is not suited for the
of processing or collecting
all the data from
enterprise systems.
So you can use
BigQuery as a data lake
so you can gather
all the data coming
from the enterprise
like application server
with server databases.
Import it to the BigQuery and
do some pre-processing on that.
Then it can output exported
data as a training data
to the TensorFlow or ML engine.
So let's take a look at the
actual demonstration for that.
Here, I'd like to
use the Cloud Data
Lab to use the BigQuery for
preparation or pre-processing
and use a TensorFlow to train
the neural network model
for machine learning analytics.
So this is the sample code
I have prepared that is
called Classifying Manhattan.
Here, we are importing a
bunch of the location data
from BigQuery and training
the neural network model
to classify whether each
location is Manhattan or not.
So we clear all the cells first.
And let's take a look
at what kind of training
data set we'll be using
by executing this query.
So I will be using
another public data
set called NYPD collisions.
That records all
the car accidents
that happened in New York City.
This is time stamp and borough,
latitude and longitude.
But you cannot use
this row data as it is.
You have to do
pre-processing to that
because you can see that some
rows doesn't have any borough
data.
Some rows don't have any
latitude and longitude.
And then we have to remove
those useless garbage data.
So again, you can use
the BigQuery to do
this kind of pre-processing.
And also I want to
have a new program--
it's Manhattan--
to have a flag that
represents whether the
latitude and longitude is
inside Manhattan or not.
So this is the [INAUDIBLE] I'll
be using for pre-processing
and let me execute it.
And also, you can also
execute another code
to extract all the
data from BigQuery,
import it into the Python.
So now you have all the data
imported into Python code.
So as you can see, by
using Cloud Data Lab,
you can seamlessly
integrate the BigQuery query
with the Python code you write.
And you can continue
to use your [INAUDIBLE]
or the NumPy code
running on BigQuery.
Sorry about my voice.
So now we have the
training data set.
One is the east Manhattan--
this could be used as a label
for training, whether each
location is in Manhattan
or not--
and pairs of the latitude and
longitude for 10,000 rows.
So let's do the feature scaling.
Before starting in training,
usually in machine learning,
you have to clean the data out--
pulling out or
cleansing of the data.
One Important thing to do
is the feature scaling.
And if you do the scaling
and plotting the data,
you can see the training data
set would look like this.
Now everything is
centered on the 0.
But still you can see the
shape of the Manhattan here,
and can even see
there's a Central
Park inside the data set.
So this will be the training
data set for neural network.
We'll be splitting the data
into training data and test data
and use TensorFlow to
define your neural network.
Here, I'm using TensorFlow,
especially the so-called high--
what is that-- high
level API of TensorFlow.
This is one of the
features we have recently
announced with TensorFlow
1.0 where you can just
learn a few lines of Python
code to define neural networks.
Before that, we have been
using so-called low level API
where you have to define all
the computation graph, low level
competition graph, to
define your own network.
But now you can just write a
few lines of code with Python.
So you can see we are
defining deep neural networks
with the four hidden layers.
And each hidden
layer has 20 nodes.
So we have the [INAUDIBLE]
neural networks.
Let's check the current
accuracy of the neural networks
and how these
neural networks can
classify the Manhattan
with that before doing
the actual training.
So now you'll be seeing
the map [INAUDIBLE]
by the neural networks.
So this is how the neural
network thinks where
Manhattan is before training.
So because this is
before training,
the neural network is too
stupid to classify Manhattan.
He thinks this is in Manhattan.
So this is where we have to
train the neural network model.
The accuracy is 75%.
So you can write a for loop to
repeat [INAUDIBLE] called a fit
method to train the model by
using the training data set.
So now it's showing the--
gradually showing
the better accuracy.
So you are seeing that
neural network model
is trying to adjust how
to classify each data
point to get better results.
So that network is getting
much smarter and smarter
as you have saw on the
playground demonstration.
Yes, it's getting
much, much better.
So now that the
writing is finished,
we got the 99.8% accuracy.
And now neural network is
trying to split the Manhattan
and Brooklyn with the
very sophisticated
[INAUDIBLE] between them.
So this is how you
can combine BigQuery
for pre-processing
and TensorFlow
to do the better
analytics on it.
So that was use case number
one, using the BigQuery
for pre-processing.
And use case number two is to
use the BigQuery for signature
based search based on the result
you got from the data model
you're trying to use a
machine learning engine.
We use the ML Engine for
extracting the feature vectors.
So I'd like to show
another demonstration
of BigQueryItSmart.
So if you go to
QueryIt Smart, you
have the other demonstration
called Image Search.
And you can choose
one of the key images.
Let me try with the elephant.
So we'll be using this
elephant image as a key image,
and compared 1 million
images with this key image
to find the similar
images on BigQuery.
I got it.
And BigQuery has
processed 8.8 gigabit data
of the 1 million
images in 10 seconds.
And all you see is
the similar images.
And you may notice that you
also have the images that
is not elephant like this.
This is not an elephant.
But still it looks similar
to the neural networks.
And this is apparently
is not an animal.
It's a statue.
But still, the
neural network thinks
it must be a similar thing.
This is not an elephant
but it has the same kind
of the texture or patterns.
So the neural network
thinks they are similar.
So this is not a keyword
search or pattern matching,
but they are comparing all the
feature vectors or signatures
of the image.
So you can get a much smarter
search on the BigQuery.
So how do you do this?
At first, we have imported
all the 1 million images
from Wikimedia on the
Google Cloud Storage.
And then we have used Machine
Learning Engine, ML Engine,
to learn the convolutional
neural networks on the ML
Engine.
This is a typical neural
network design used
for the analyzing the images.
But usually, people
are using CNN
to get the labels for the
images such as, is it a cat?
Is it a human face?
Is it a flower?
But instead of
getting labels, we
are using CNN to
extract the feature
vectors that could be in the
signatures of the old images.
And by using the
BigQuery and UGF,
you can do this immediately
search against images.
And we have used VGG16, which
is a popular CNN design.
And we are extracting the future
vectors from the final fully
[? connectional ?] layers.
And you can do this by writing
a very simple TensorFlow
code like this.
So you can specify which way you
want to extract a vector from.
And then it can learn
the GCloud [? command ?]
to execute a Cloud
ML job to extract
the features from the images.
Usually, it takes
hours to learn the jobs
against the millions of images.
So then now we
have the signatures
of images, feature vectors.
And you can find the similarity
of distance between the vectors
defined as similar images.
Again, we are using the UGF
to calculate the similarity
between the two vectors.
It's a very simple math.
And you can use the
UGF in your own SQL,
rank the ordering by the
distance between the vectors.
And it's so inexpensive.
If you run this query
against 1 million images,
it would only cost $0.86.
So it's not so expensive.
So that was the things
I wanted to share
to-- how you can combine the
ML Engine machine learning
with BigQuery by using
the feature vectors.
And at first, I direct to
share another interesting use
case of the BigQuery, which
is large-scale demand focus.
OK, I try to go back
to the QueryIt Smart
to show another cool demo.
This demonstration is for
speculating or forecasting
the demand for New
York City bikes.
So, as a public data set
we have all the record
for usage for New York City
bikes for past few years.
And by training the
neural network model
by using the past
history, you can
do the demand focus against
[INAUDIBLE] by the conditions
like the month in
a year or a day
in a week or weather or
the temperature of the day.
And you can forecast
how much usage
you would get with specified
conditions by using BigQuery.
Usually, people will be using
things like Apache Hadoop
or SPARC or maybe
Dataflow to this kind
of the complex analytics
against your big data.
But now you can use
BigQuery, just BigQuery,
to implement this.
So what you are seeing
is the animated hit maps.
That shows the
increases or decreases
of the demands for each other.
And we have over 600 stations,
bike stations, in Manhattan.
And by using
BigQuery, you can do
the massively powerful demand
forecast for hundreds of points
within tens of seconds.
Usually, you have to
wait tens of minutes
before finishing
the Apache Hadoop
job to this kind of the
sophisticated analytics,
but you can use the
BigQuery to do this thing
and get the result up
in the tens of seconds.
So, how do you do this?
We have defined our neural
networks for demand forecast
and trained the model
by using the ML Engine.
And then you can import all
the neural network model
to the cloud storage so that
BigQuery user-defined function,
or UDF can read the model
from the cloud storage
into UDF to do the
prediction inside UDF
So you can define UDF like this.
As you can see, you can define
very simple neural networks
by using JavaScript in UDF.
If you have read any
textbooks for neural networks,
you may remember that people
will be using Python or Java
code to write this kind
of the [INAUDIBLE] code.
But in this case, we have used
JavaScript running on BigQuery
to implement the prediction
for neural network.
And also you can import
all the weights and biases
parameters loaded into BigQuery
by using Google Cloud Storage.
And with UDF, you can
upload up to five megabytes
of any kind of data into UDF.
So you have to compress
everything into five megabytes.
So that's the trick.
So I want to note that these
techniques I'm showing,
which is the combinations
between the BigQuery UDF
and Machine Learning
Engines, can be applied
to any kind of applications.
And it thinks you can
calculate the feature vectors
of signatures out of it.
And the most
important part here is
that you can let all the
non-engineers or non-data
scientists using these
machine learning technologies.
So once you have data scientists
or ML engineers define the UDF
and train the model
with ML Engine,
you can let all
the enterprises use
this using UDF to do the
analytics, [INAUDIBLE]
analytics for daily tasks.
So you can-- sorry
about my voice.
So you can apply
these technologies
for demand forecast or
recommendation for the products
or who will be the
users who behaves
like this particular users to
find out what the premium users
or cheating users or
spam users or what
would be the similar
[INAUDIBLE] like this
or the recommendation.
Or you can even apply
the technologies
for the IOT applications.
So if you have any
target signal data,
you can do the similar
search on the signals
from the IOT devices to
find any defective devices
on the IOT platform, the
kind of the use cases.
So let me summarize.
So you can use the--
BigQuery provides the fully
managed petabyte-scale data
warehouse.
It provides the
economy of cloud.
It's easy to use.
And also the UDF,
User-Defined Function,
is so useful and
powerful computing
tool that could be utilized
to analyze the signatures
or feature vectors of
any kind of its contents
rather than using just a simple
keyword pattern matching.
And you can combine the UDF with
Machine Learning Engine, or ML
Engine, to extract
the signatures
by using the training
data set created by humans
so that you can extract the
sense or instinct of humans
to realize this
smarter analytics.
And these techniques,
UDF plus ML,
is available for any kind
of users in the enterprise.
You can allow all
the enterprise users
taking advantage of the
power of the machine learning
for everyday tasks.
So if you're interested
in these technologies,
you can go to the GitHub and
search with QueryIt Smart.
We already have
published all the source
code I have used on GitHub.
So please take a look at.
And I'd like to give
a special thanks
to Tomoyuki Chikanaga
who built all the sample
codes I have shared today.
And there are some
other sessions
related to machine learning
and BigQuery and big data
processing.
So if you are interested,
please take a look
at those sessions too.
So thank you so much.